cortney's with us in New Orleans hot
Courtney welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi thank you so much for talking with me
today my husband and I have had a
wonderful few years and he and I both
been really fortunate in our careers and
also blessed with our first little one
yeah and we in fact have been so
fortunate in our career is that we've
we've had a point that we are pretty
certain we could live fairly comfortably
off one income and I'm really
contemplating leaving my job to stay at
home with our with our excuse me with
our one and a half year old but I am
having a really hard time making that
decision and pulling the trigger and you
know the idea of leaving what are you
doing so far I work remotely for an
advertising firm and what do you like I
make about 120 and what does he make he
makes about 140 how much debt do you
guys have we have zero debt we're in
baby steps for five in sex
so it's a great problem to have but
really we've we've been so fortunate to
be able to save I'm sorry what are you
doing for the advertising firm I work in
our corporate consulting team and I've
been with our firm for about 15 years
what do you tactically do what is your
job description I am a director and our
firm and I work with our some of our
corporate clients on reputation and
positioning okay okay good brand
positioning all right good
well there's a couple things pop into my
head one is if you're gonna quit and you
want to quit you should okay you want to
be home with this baby your husband
makes 120 thousand dollars a year your
own baby step four touchdown quit okay
if you want to be sure that that's what
you want to do financially you could say
for 90 days we're going to bank 100% of
my check and
run the budget as if it was his because
that's what you're about to take on
right and that's that could be like your
little acid test and then you would feel
emotionally a lot more comfortable I
mean when you just say out loud I've got
to live on 120 thousand dollars a year
well when most people can figure that
out right so yeah do it
the second thing so that that's the
basics yes you should follow your heart
on this there's nothing wrong with what
you're doing
you could be raising the next president
of the United States I don't know it
could be a really great job you have
right there okay so the not the next one
but a president the United States
probably not the next one
but the unless this one becomes emperor
but anyway no god help us
but anyway aside from that the second
thing that pops into my head is you are
doing branding obviously we have a lot
of marketing folks on our team here that
do similar things and you know
positioning with individual clients you
could do a lot of that during nap time
and go part-time remote and you know
keep a couple of key clients that you
have act you know really good
relationships with that would be
advantageous to you and your firm and
you know go to halftime or something and
make 60 while the kids asleep I mean you
really that's very possible from a you
know a time management type of a thing
and for that matter you could afford a
nanny to come in and and just to be
there in the house with you for a few
hours a week not full-time but just a
few hours a week to enable you to mean
you can pay somebody 10 grand a year and
able you to make 60 right
and still be there and be mom you know
will you be a full-time mom still but
just if they start screaming while
you're in the middle of a Skype call or
something cuz I woke up from their nap
then you wouldn't have that you'd have
somebody to step in there right that
kind of thing you don't have to do that
but if you but but what is running
through my head is you are a very well
accomplished lady executive
and so my guess is you're not miserable
at work you just want to be with a baby
absolutely and you know we've been
really fortunate both of us in our
careers and you know just grappling with
leaving behind what I what I know I kind
of think you might want to scratch that
itch just from a self identity
professional thing you don't have to you
don't financially have to but if you
just wanted to that's a way you could do
it is just keep a few key clients if the
agency once you do if not you could just
do some side branding as a hustle as a
side pocket is it morally wrong to leave
that kind of you know income and
opportunity on the table know when who
knows what you know we don't know what
life breathe no listen you didn't leave
your brains on the table you didn't
leave your experience or your education
on the table they're still in your
pocket and if you need to do something
you can go back and do it but basically
you know what I'll reverse engineer that
on you that's a phrase I'm using today
for some reason but let's just let's
just say is it morally wrong to take a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year to be away from your kids you know
that's that's a guilt trip the other way
right so there's lots of guilt trips to
go around in motherhood but no you're
not morally wrong to raise your kids I
mean you know I always think about
somebody like Billy Graham his mother or
Franklin Graham's mother for that matter
Billy's wife right and you think okay
wouldn't you like to have had that job
you know when you like to have had Abe
Lincoln's mother's job you know would
have been morally wrong for her to go be
a professional lady and miss out on the
training and the income or whatever that
no it's not the whole thing is God gave
you a sets of skills and to get a few
sets of instincts and you know you're
gonna use those at different parts at
different seasons of your life and right
now you got a baby at home and you want
to be there with that baby and you only
got one shot at that and that's what you
want to do I'm with you I'm with you I
want you to do it I wouldn't tell you to
do it if I thought you're gonna lose
your house or something like that that's
not what we're discussed
we're just talking about how fast you
all build wealth versus not fast
whoopty doopty yeah all you got these
looking at kids eyes while you're
changing the diaper and you'll have to
answer that question you'll know you're
not morally wrong
you're not morally wrong it on and
you're not morally wrong if you wanted
to keep doing it either that's not a not
a bad thing to be in a lady executive if
that's what you want to be but you got a
pretty clear situation here I think
you're gonna do something part-time on
the side while kiddos sleeping because I
think you're going to want to scratch
that edge but that's not a moral
statement or a spiritual statement or
even a financial statement I think
that's more of a career coaching thing I
just think you're going to want that
part of your brain activated because I
think that's who you are after talking
to you but you're just too articulate
and so forth but if you want to apply
all of those skills to full-time
motherhood and not make another dime for
the next 32 years I'm fine with that
that's what my wife did and she's very
very bright and very well-read and very
accomplished and I was a now she's
full-time me me the keeper of Rufus the
Shih Tzu and somebody's got to do it
right